[Música]
es un gusto saludarlos Soy Paula Jiménez
Correa y les doy la bienvenida Así es
Asia el magazine quincenal de France 24
que aborda las múltiples realidades de
este continente Estos son nuestros
titulares
5 millones de personas fueron puestas en
confinamiento de manera indefinida en la
ciudad de China debido a los creyentes
casos de Kobe 19 que se vienen
registrando desde hace algunas semanas y
que representan según las autoridades
uno de los peores brotes del virus en
seis meses escuelas y partes del
transporte público han sido cerrados
hasta nueva orden del gobierno que
insiste en su política de cerocovis
Tokio la capital de Japón empezó a
expedir certificados a parejas del mismo
sexo con el fin de permitirles ser
tratados como personas casadas y recibir
algunos beneficios en materias de salud
y de vivienda en un país en el que el
matrimonio homosexual aún no está
reconocido para muchos aunque aún falta
camino por recorrer Este es un pequeño
paso hacia la igualdad de género en la
sociedad japonesa
y cuando la tierra cultivable escasea
cualquier espacio urbano podría
utilizarse para llenar estos vacíos eso
es lo que se ha implementado en el metro
de Taiwán en donde Los viajeros pueden
comprar ensaladas recién sacadas de los
estantes
iniciamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente asiático en China donde
siguen los cierres por los crecientes
casos de Kobe 19 en varias regiones una
de las más afectadas en la ciudad de en
el sur del país pues allí las
autoridades han ordenado el
confinamiento de millones de personas
debido a que recientes informes indican
que a diario se están presentando
alrededor de 3000 casos lo que supone
más de un tercio de todo lo reportados
en el país Medellín la capital también
ha redoblado la realización de pruebas
masivas ante el aumento de positivos
obligando así al cierre de escuelas y
una parte del sector comercial las
opiniones frente a estas medidas son
diversas
estoy familiarizado con esta situación
porque tenía cinco empresas en jenseng
Hong Kong etcétera Pero algunas cerraron
y ahora solo quedan dos en Beijing hay
mucha presión para que las empresas
sobrevivan y tengo amigos que manejan
negocios por lo que sé el 80% de ellos
está cerca del colapso mientras que
algunos están pasando por una transición
o buscando otras redes comerciales es
bastante difícil para nosotros
sobrevivir
con cosas
yo trabajo cerca mi empresa no le pedía
al personal que se hiciera las pruebas
de Kobe 19 todos los días era una
cuestión del barrio estas pruebas no
solo nos protegen a nosotros sino
también a los demás en términos de cómo
esto afecta nuestra vida todavía Creo
que es manejable
nuestro corresponsal en Beijing Adrián
foncillas tiene más detalles
cinco de los 19 millones de habitantes
de la ciudad sureña de guanyol ya están
confinados el primer Distrito fue
cerrado el fin de semana Ayer fueron
cerrados otros dos por una duración
indefinida los que viven en las zonas de
medio y bajo riesgo sólo pueden salir a
comprar víveres los que viven en las de
alto riesgo tienen que esperar a que se
los lleven Allí se repitieron las
escenas de compras frenéticas que
vaciaron los supermercados además en
buena parte de la ciudad se ha
suspendido el transporte público y se
han cerrado las escuelas wang you lleva
lidiando con un brote durante semanas al
principio con medidas quirúrgicas
siguiendo las últimas instrucciones del
gobierno de intentar que la política
cero covid afecte cuanto menos a la
economía y a la vida pero nada de eso ha
funcionado y ahora se han redoblado las
restricciones con el fin último de
evitar un encierro total y tan
traumático como el que sufrió chanjai
cuando yo la antigua cantones son
principal centro facturero del Sur del
país con una gran presencia del de la
Industria Del textil y automovilística
también es un importante centro de
comunicaciones con uno de los
aeropuertos más transitados del país
esta mañana había tenido que cancelar el
85% de los vuelos china sufre el peor
brote en 6 meses siguen las
restricciones en ciudades como genjoy
donde está la mayor fábrica de iphones
del mundo o Pekín en la capital han
bastado un centenar de casos para que se
cerraran la mayor parte de las escuelas
vamos a Tokio la capital de Japón allí
las parejas homosexuales celebraron la
decisión de la alcaldía de empezar a
reconocer a las parejas homosexuales
para acceder algunos servicios básicos
pero aún no les otorga los mismos
derechos que tienen las parejas
heterosexuales a pesar de esta decisión
local la lucha contra la discriminación
hacia la comunidad lgbtiq+ sigue siendo
un tabú a nivel nacional y no se
vislumbran cambios legislativos que
reconozcan la unión de estas parejas en
el futuro cercano Japón sigue siendo el
único país miembro del g7 que no
reconoce a las parejas homosexuales
veamos el informe de Samuel Salgado
una decisión que alivia las personas del
mismo sexo en Tokio pero que para muchos
es aún insuficiente en la lucha contra
la discriminación hacia la comunidad
lgbtiq más la alcaldía de la capital
lipona comenzó a emitir desde inicios de
noviembre certificados de asociación a
parejas gay que Residen y trabajan en
Tokio así como a parejas de otras
regiones que visiten la ciudad
como somos una pareja del mismo sexo no
podemos registrarnos como casados
legalmente nuestras familias nuestros
padres entienden nuestra relación pero
no contamos con nada público que
demuestre que tenemos una relación por
lo tanto planeamos solicitar el
certificado de asociación de Tokio
con estos certificados las parejas
homosexuales Serán tratadas como no
Unión matrimonial en el momento de
acceder a servicios públicos como la
salud la vivienda y la seguridad social
sin embargo no tendrán los mismos
derechos ni reconocimiento que las
parejas heterosexuales por matrimonio lo
que impulsa activistas a seguir
exigiendo reconocimiento a nivel
nacional
significa mucho
poniendo al resto del país todavía hay
áreas donde la comprensión de miembros
lgbtq más es bajo Espero que este evento
tenga un impacto en esas áreas
el Primer Ministro de Japón
prefiere ser cauteloso sobre la
posibilidad de cambios legislativos que
reconozcan la unión de parejas del mismo
sexo en todo el territorio algo que es
consecuente a la ideología conservadora
del partido liberal democrático
Movimiento Político al cual quisiera
pertenece pero la resistencia del
premiere no ha impedido que más de 200
autoridades locales ya hayan avanzado en
el reconocimiento de la asociación de
parejas homosexuales siendo el distrito
de shibuya pionero en emitir estos
decretos en 2015 desde entonces la lucha
por el reconocimiento en Japón ha tenido
avances y retrocesos a nivel
constitucional
cuando tuvimos una fiesta de bodas el
mes pasado todos sus parientes de la
familia de Mickey se unieron a nosotras
Para apoyar nuestra relación entonces me
preguntaron por qué el gobierno ha
tardado tanto en reconocer el matrimonio
entre personas del mismo sexo algunos
políticos han hecho comentarios
realmente negativos como que somos
enfermas repugnantes
[Música]
la decisión de Tokio es una esperanza
para Mickey y Katy de que la sociedad
nipona vea con normalidad la unión de
parejas homosexuales un paso más contra
la discriminación a las comunidades
sexuales diversas
si es Asia y se lo contamos 24 Estos son
otros hechos destacados que marcan la
agenda del continente
en Afganistán los talibanes prohibieron
la entrada de mujeres a los parques
públicos y ferias de atracciones de
kabul la capital esto apenas unos meses
después de Ordenar el acceso segregado
por género la nueva regla introducida
esta semana aísla aún más a las mujeres
de un espacio público cada vez más
reducido que ya les podido viajar sin
una acompañante masculino y las obliga a
usar un hillab o burka cuando están
fuera de casa
en Indonesia miles de fanáticos del
fútbol protestaron en Java Oriental
exigiendo una mayor investigación sobre
la conducta y respuesta policial a la
estampida que mató a 135 personas
después de un partido el pasado primero
de octubre la comisión de derechos
humanos de ese país ha dicho que el
lanzamiento de gases lacrimógenos por
parte de los agentes fue el principal
desencadenante de la tragedia en el
estadio de malang considerada como la
peor en un partido de fútbol desde 1964
seis personas incluidos la policía y los
organizadores del partido enfrentan
cargos penales por este hecho
en India crece la preocupación por los
altos niveles de contaminación que se
vienen registrando en varias ciudades
entre ellas Nueva Delhi la capital en
donde las autoridades se han visto
obligadas a ordenar el cierre de
escuelas fábricas y prohibir las
actividades de construcción o la
circulación de vehículos comerciales
dice no esenciales además de tráfico de
camiones pesados la concentración de
partículas pm2.5 ha llegado a superar la
Barrera de los 300 microgramos por metro
cúbico de aire unos niveles que
multiplican las cifras consideradas
seguras por la Organización Mundial de
la Salud
una empresa de tecnología en Taiwán se
unió al operador de metro de la isla
para cultivar productos orgánicos dentro
de las estaciones de metro con el
objetivo de aprovechar los espacios
vacíos y potenciar la sostenibilidad las
verduras y ensaladas también se venden a
Los viajeros ocupados desde un puesto
cercano haciendo de este negocio algo
muy Dinámico
aquellos que toman el metro en la
capital de Taiwán pueden apreciar algo
inusual
una granja hidropónica que cultiva
productos frescos incluida la lechuga
llamada metro Fresh en la granja utiliza
un espacio vacío en el metro para crear
un ambiente estéril que permita evitar
el uso de pesticidas y herbicidas
usamos luces led para reemplazar la luz
solar la ventaja es que podemos
controlar la cantidad de tiempo que
estas plantas hidropónicas reciben luz
además esta granja hidropónica está
apilada verticalmente por lo que
funciona mejor en condiciones de suelo
urbano restrictivas estas granjas
interiores también conocidas como
granjas inteligentes se Están volviendo
cada vez más populares en Taiwán donde
solo el 25% de la tierra es apta para la
agricultura también requieren menos mano
de obra que la agricultura tradicional
están protegidas del cambio climático y
producen mayores rendimientos de
cultivos en este momento nuestro
rendimiento de producciones de 180
bolsas de lechuga cada bolsa Tiene 200
gramos podemos producir 180 bolsas de
lechuga por semana
es un concepto que Taiwán también espera
exportar el grupo del país ya se asoció
con la empresa danesa de agrotecnología
nórdica para construir una instalación
de 7000 metros cuadrados en coppenhagen
la isla también está buscando expandir
el rendimiento de sus cultivos con la
esperanza de suministrar gran parte de
las frutas y verduras del mundo en los
próximos 30 años y para el cierre les
dejo algunos datos Rusia además de ser
el país más grande del mundo es también
el país más extenso de Asia Pues cuenta
con más de 17 millones de kilómetros
cuadrados de superficie
Encontraste el país más pequeño de Asia
era República de maldivas con una
superficie aproximada de 298 kilómetros
cuadrados
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
las redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web France 24.com y no
olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]